hi everyone welcome to another video
today we're looking at parameter
prediction for unseen deep architectures
and we have a special guest today boris
niezef who is the first author of this
paper actually so this is a first
i guess for boris and for myself to
review a paper in a bit of an interview
style the plan is that we go through the
paper together there's also been some
reception in the public because as you
might have heard the paper claims to be
able to predict the parameters of an of
a of a neural network without you having
to train the neural network at least i
guess that's the
the overhype
that then leads to people saying wait a
minute that can't be true
and we'll go exactly through this we'll
look at what they've done right here and
um yeah boris welcome
welcome so much to the the channel thank
you for a great introduction i am very
excited uh to be here as well
so i'm ready to
take uh any critique from you
so how did this this come to be you're
you're at the university of guelph and
and there's i see vector institute
facebook ai research and the the github
is under facebook research yeah um
how did this come to be
so this project uh i started as an
intern at facebook ai
uh
in summer 2020 so more than a year ago
and
all and our collaborators are from
facebook ai so met meta-ai
right
and yeah
that's why
we decided to keep uh the code on the
facebook research
so yeah yeah cool excellent and if we
can i mean let's let's dive in um right
here essentially essentially what we've
we've said so far is you have some kind
of a neural network with whatever a
bunch of layers and a bunch of
computational nodes and you have the
weights in between somehow right so w1
w2 weight matrices but not only that you
have normalization you have any kinds of
things and usually we have some data set
x and we have some result y we train
with back propagation to find the best
parameters but in your case you went
ahead and you essentially built this
hyper network uh hyper graph network
that is able to take in if i remember
correctly the data right yeah
and the architecture like the structure
here of the weight matrices all of this
goes in and
into a neural network which is a graph
neural network right yeah and
and so some sort of a graph neural
network will go into that what exactly
this and out comes the these weight
matrices
uh so and you're able to do this
without training the weight matrices
ever so you just predict them yeah so
what one correction here
the network this hyper network doesn't
take data as input it's trained on
specific data set say c410 or imagenet
but
at test time it doesn't take
data as an input it only takes a network
as input
and that's why yeah it cannot generalize
to
other data sets
okay so it is you do experiments that i
see here on c410
and on imagenet uh so these are two
different let's say hyper networks that
you train you train one for c410 and you
train another one for imagenet well in
fact i train many many networks
sure sure but but it's not one network
that is going to predict the parameters
of of for any data set no yeah so we
release one network for c410 and one
network for imagenet correct okay and
this so here you say by leveraging
advances in graph neural network we
propose a hyper network that can predict
performance parameters in a single
forward pass so the single forward pass
what does that refer to it means that i
feed the architecture one single time
through the graph neural network or yeah
so this phrase is to highlight the
difference between say recurrent
networks where
uh so there are some meta optimizers
right and they can also do something
similar to our work but they require
like many iterations in our case like
it's a single propagation basically
through the graph yeah yeah and then you
you get these you get these uh these
parameters out which is i mean that
that's that's pretty cool and then you
say
um
on imagenet oh sorry on c410 you reach a
60 accuracy and on imagenet you reach a
top five accuracy now these are let's
say they're respectable numbers they're
better than random but they're way way
below
anywhere you know near what i could get
by actually training a network that's
was this
urine or was this your intention or is
this is it still surprising that you get
this good numbers
yeah yeah it's still very surprising to
me and to other co-authors and to many
other people i guess
uh because
it's very hard like when you have a
novel network
uh the assumption is that
you know you cannot
predict parameters for that like if you
predict it will be like some garbage
neurons so because uh
there is a complex
complex
interactions between neurons
uh so it's very hard yeah for a novel
network you yeah it's very hard
that's the assumption
uh i don't know okay make sense
of course it makes sense of course yeah
i mean it's it is it is in a way it's
you know the numbers aren't good but
they are certainly good for never having
you know trained um yeah but there is a
bit of a because the the hyper network
has been trained on that specific data
set and maybe we'll go a little bit into
uh your what you exactly train this on
so you introduce a new data set which is
this deepness one m data set right could
you tell us a little bit about this so
this is the essentially the basis for
learning this hyper network yes so it's
a data set of training and evaluation
architectures
and
it's called
deep nets 1m because we have 1 million
training architectures
so we predefined them and we saved them
so that
people can reproduce
training probably
and
the idea
there is some misconception that we
actually also have trained weights
for those training networks but no we
don't like we didn't train one million
architectures
uh yeah so and the architectures are
almost random
uh in the sense that the operations and
connectivity between them are
constructed in a like random way by
uniformly sampling for from a specific
space of architecture so you you define
you define a space a design space which
you call this right and this design
space consists of things like you know
you can have
you can have a convolution or you can
have an an ml or sorry you can have a
linear layer right or you can have an
attention layer right and then that's
followed by either a batch norm or a
weight norm
or not no normalization at all right and
then that's followed by
right and then you build sort of these
these combinatorical things so one
architecture would be a convolution with
a weight normalization and with
something else and then also the design
space includes kind of the parameters
for this so for the convolution you
could have
i don't know
five
three or one on one side like so i can
have a five by five convolution that has
maybe is only depth wise and not fully
convolution and so on so there are all
these
sort of nested cartesian products yeah
of this big space that you define and
then
essentially you could say you
you fix a random seed and then you
sample about a million times yeah that'd
be a fair characterization
so that you say okay
with with this we sample a million times
from a fixed random seed and that so
everyone has the same
networks to train on yeah yeah that's a
fair uh statement
and so there were some data sets like
this before to do neural architecture
search specifically but you say you've
you've extended the design space a
little bit and that so before these
networks they would include
kind of
the design space is large enough to
include sort of the modern networks but
you have
you've sort of extended that even a
little bit more right um
right right so usually those neural
architecture search works they have a
quite constrained design space because
they mainly consider very efficient
networks like efficient network or
squeeze net
mobile net but resnet is out of their
design space because
resnet is considered a waste of
resources in in in the nas community
yeah but in our work we are still
interested in predicting like these
large uh
uh
parameters let's assume that you had
actually trained all the weights for the
million architectures right and you
train your hyper network to predict
these weights and i sample a new one
and um
then
it could be fairly like someone
skeptical might say well you've probably
seen a very similar network um during
training right so you just memorize the
weights from that so there are there are
two differences here as you said you
don't actually have the trained weights
of these million architectures which i
want to come back in a second but you
also have these out of distribution
samples do you want to maybe comment on
what what are the out of distribution
architectures for this data set what do
they look like right so the industry
well i first i say what is in
distribution uh to highlight the
difference so in this in distribution is
uh the test set uh it is the same as the
like it uses the same generator to
sample architectures as the training
architectures
so
and while the architectures are still
all different
they as you said they can be quite
similar
and we actually measure that
in the appendix like we have some data
for that
so
that's one of the reasons we
designed those out of distribution
uh splits
and uh yeah the motivation was to test
particular distribution shifts for
example what happens if the networks uh
become wider like have more channels
like wide resnet instead of resnet or
for example what happens if we want to
predict the parameters for a deeper
network
say resonant yeah 150 instead of
resonant 50 right so there are these
there's sub categories right there's
wide and deep which are wider or deeper
than you've seen during training and
there is also this batch norm free
uh category right so there are various
aberrations that you didn't see
necessarily during training but yeah i
think it's fair to say that the
performance of your method still comes
from the fact that you know the network
has been trained on on certain things
it's just a matter of how how much does
it generalize to new architectures yeah
yes for sure it was trained on all
uh like operations that are
that are used to compose out of
distribution networks but it wasn't
trained on that particular
configurations like
compositions
so it's still and how just if we jump to
the results like just an aspect of the
results how how different
are the weights
from like
do you do you know what happens if you
just kind of copy over weights from the
most similar network in the training
data set
does this work at all or
have you done any kind of you know dumb
bass lines to compare i i tried but it
turned out to be more difficult uh than
it seems so you you need to come up with
many different heuristics like how to
yeah copy ways if the dimensionality
doesn't match
or like if the layers uh
like not exactly the same so there's a
lot of
those and it becomes basically a
separate research project
to develop this uh yeah dump baseline so
we didn't go in in detail with that yeah
so this is i guess this is the training
loss what's special about this as you
said you don't actually have to fully
trained weights of all of these network
networks but essentially
what you do is you sort of back
propagate
through
training these networks if i if i
understand this correctly so what you
have here is a double sum over n and m
and n here
is the number of tasks so what is a task
right here uh here
uh
task is uh so we use the terminology
from meta learning right so but here the
task is uh network okay so uh this is
the
this m is the number of training
architectures yeah and n i presume is
the data set or yes it's the number of
samples in a data set like what can you
just yeah
so we take one point one day to point x
right uh xj
and
what is the a right here that is
that is the architecture that we sample
as one of the m architectures so we take
the x we take the a and this here that's
your network that you actually want to
train right yeah so as you said it does
not get the training data point it
simply gets the architecture and it has
a set of parameters which are ultimately
the parameters we want to
optimize right
and
the so the f here i guess that is your
way of saying
take
this network
predict the weights
pass
the data point through it and get the
output yeah exactly that's a fair
characterization for forward pass of
images through the
predicted parameters to get the predict
predictions yeah so yeah f yeah f calls
if i were to program this then f would
call your network to get
f would instantiate a
would call your network with the
architecture will get back the weights
put that into a and pass the data point
through
once yeah yeah exactly and then we
simply compare it to the label right
which we which we have and then i i
guess this loss right here is cross
entropy loss or whatever is appropriate
for the data set yeah yeah so you can
basically reduce this equation to
equation one
if you
if you freeze the architecture
so if you if m
is equal one
uh and instead of having a hyper network
you have like fixed weights uh
w uh w
uh
then it's the same objective
and it's the same loss and then you
learn by
back propagating if i if i see this
correctly so usually what we do is
we forward pass x through this thing
right and then we back propagate to
these weights right here
but
what we do is we simply continue back
propagating through the weight
generating function
into the hyper network yeah and all of
this is all of this is differentiable i
guess the weights are floating point
numbers and
the way the graph network works is all
differentiable so you can essentially
back propagate it through the parameters
here so every i guess every
part of the graph neural network would
have weights
and you can back propagate it through
that okay yeah i mean that seems
reasonable enough oh this connection
here that's not
that's not happening no data to the
graph network for now yeah cool um this
seems it seems pretty straightforward so
now maybe we talk about what exactly the
graph neural network is getting as
uh features and when when we talk about
graph neural networks it's it's always a
bit
um there are many flavors of graph
neural networks but i'm going to try to
characterize it um
briefly so we have nodes in the graph
neural network and each node has a bunch
of features initially so each node gets
a bunch of like a vector of different
features in our case the nodes
each would refer to
different
operations different modules right so
this here could be this cure could be
the conv the convolutional uh
the convolutional layer in the first
layer this then could be the batch norm
that follows in the first layer and this
could be the convolution in the second
layer and so on so we connect
the graph neural network in the same way
that the architecture is connected right
so so the graph neural network changes
from architecture to architecture
oh uh
the graph no no the graph neural network
is fixed
so the graph neural network itself
doesn't have no it doesn't have nodes
right the graph network will not have
weights
like uh theta right and this theta are
basically like uh a matrix uh with the
number of input features and the number
of output features
yeah uh so the those weights are fixed
uh
what is changing is the input that is
represented as a graph i see so this
here maybe we can more characterize as
the input yes and that goes into
that goes into
a let's say a standard neural network
with a bunch of layers yeah but the
input is essentially what you call i
think a which is the it's an adjacency
matrix yeah so this graph would be
described by an adjacency matrix matrix
and
for luck i don't exactly remember how
you called it but let's call it f the
features yeah of each of the nodes right
and these things will go into the neural
network and out would come your your
different uh weights for
for the graph yeah yeah and
yeah so the way graph neuro this these
graph neural networks work is each node
essentially starts with a bunch of
features here right this has a vector
this has a vector and then you apply
these functions so every layer here
would correspond to one message
propagation step
if i understand this correctly where all
of the neighbors they would sort of pass
messages to each other
given
differentiable functions
so if we consider this node it would
sort of receive
from all its neighbors it would receive
messages it would compute some sort of
hidden state and then in the next
iteration it would pass that hidden
state to
its neighbors right right this is the
basic functionality now you in your
particular
case have opted for
a bit of a
more advanced architecture right here
that more mirrors sort of the the
propagation in a neural network can you
talk a little bit about that maybe right
so
we actually we are doing almost the same
as the previous work on graph hyper
network so i wanted to clarify that the
training objective like equation 2
and the
graph hyper network architecture is
almost
the same as the previous work but yeah
it they didn't release the open source
code so we had to like uh reinvent
something yeah
of course uh but
uh
so uh
sorry what's what was the question
so maybe maybe before that i want to i
want to just for people who may not know
graph neural networks it seems like
there's a lot going on but essentially a
graph neural network boils down to just
a few functions because what i've
described right here this i receive i
receive the hidden states from all my
neighbors and i integrate that right
this function is in fact the same
function as you know the node over here
which also receives stuff from all its
neighbors and integrates that that would
be the same function with the same
weights right it's just that the inputs
are different because of course for the
node here in the middle it has different
neighbors than the node here but the
weights of that function that takes
messages and integrates them that's the
same for all the nodes and that's why
graph neural networks very often
surprisingly can have very little
parameters and can achieve a lot of
power
um yeah and then
so so all these these steps right here i
think you've implemented them as a
recurrent neural network that simply
passes on so we would do multiple rounds
of these steps
and then right the nodes would in
multiple steps compute
updates and updates and up so even
you could implement this as separate
functions you could say time step one is
one function time step two is a function
time step 3 is another function but
you've even chosen or i guess previous
work as well chosen to implement this as
a recurrent network so not only are all
the functions
across the nodes the same but even
across the time steps they are
essentially the same because it's a
recurrent neural network so surprisingly
little parameters
and the advantage of it is i can pass in
any graph right the graphs they don't
have to be the same they can be totally
different and i can apply the same
function because it's essentially
vectorized across the whole graph which
is going to play into your your batching
methodology as well i guess once we come
to that but my question was essentially
you've so you do this
first iteration right here so the first
iteration is just like a regular graph
neural network and then the second
iteration sort of your your improved
version this gh and two yeah it has a
bunch of it but has a bunch of
um
tricks tricks right here no no that's
not even that's not even that i think
that's already in the in the previous
version is that your message passing
algorithm if i understand correctly
isn't as straightforward as here it's
not just i get from all my neighbors but
you have two different message passing
algorithms one
mimics the forward pass through the
neural network and one mimics the
backward pass so in one round i would
only get messages from my dependents
yeah and in one round i would get the
messages from my like upstream depend ds
yeah exactly
so that was part of previous work as
well or yeah yeah they developed this
specific uh like version of gated graph
neural network that mimics this behavior
uh of forward and backward propagation
and yeah
what we found though that
just one round of propagation is enough
so
uh we only do it once forward and once
backward yeah we don't okay you can't do
it multiple times
but we found it's just wastes uh yeah
resources so it doesn't improve accuracy
for some reason
so essentially training your hyper
network
exactly mirrors training a real
network in that you do a forward prop
and a backward prop
but yeah what you do is you simply back
propagate that through the weights to
the actual graph neural network weights
yeah yeah so in that sense yeah it
mimics how the networks are trained like
yeah and so now i guess what you get out
then is sorry to come back to this again
but every node sort of keeps updating
its hidden state as this progresses and
at the end you have a hidden state for
each node which is kind of the final
hidden state and then you put that into
into a
decoder
thing this thing right here so there how
do you how do you deal with the fact
that you know sometimes a convolution
has
three by three by five parameters and
sometimes it has you know yeah seven by
seven by ten parameters and sometimes
it's an attention network that needs
query key and value how does a single
architecture produce
a different number
you can reshape right but even but
especially different number of
parameters
yeah so that's actually the tricky part
and uh with
we didn't we did something very naive
actually and there is a lot of room for
improvement in that part
and what we did is uh we
applied this styling strategy
and we defined the first we defined the
tensor of like a fixed
what we call maximum shape
uh and if we need to predict a larger
uh
tensor
uh we tile it multiple times across uh
channel dimensions as needed so
essentially the tiling means right
copying the same tensor multiple times
to make it a full shape
and if we tile too much then we slice it
and uh yeah and we slice along the all
four dimensions like height weeds and
channel dimensions so it's quite naive
and
limits the
expressive capacity
of the predicted parameters but
that's the
yeah yeah that's the only method we
could make work like in the efficient
way so far
so there's yeah i guess there's room for
some sort of
weight
up sampling some some sort of technique
where you don't have to know
the number of outputs uh before you
predict those outputs right yeah yeah
like some more yeah or recurrent
networks like that to put
predict parameters uh as as much as you
need like uh sort of like in this yeah
one at a time yeah yeah or or something
like do you know these these um nerf
or siren these implicit neural networks
so essentially you give
the x and y coordinate of a picture as
an input and then it would simply
predict that particular pixel
right you could do something here where
you could parameterize maybe a weight
matrix from zero to one and you could
just say you know or
not even from zero to one but you could
you could parameterize it somehow and
you could just ask the network give me
the output at this location and at this
location
yeah yeah that's an interesting idea
actually yeah but okay i guess the other
regressive part might be more might be
more useful because you want to somehow
coordinate the weights with the other
weights you've already produced
yeah so yeah that's also a tricky part
so yeah so you you make some
improvements right right here that you
also highlight which is
okay the differentiable normalization
which um you want to comment on on that
briefly what what's new here uh so in
the original graph hyper networks uh
they predict parameters and they use
them they use those predicted parameters
parameters directly in the forward pass
and during training we found that they
start to explode like uh
similar to uh i guess you know other
kinds of uh training
uh and
so yeah predict parameters to really
become a huge and
what we found useful is to normalize
them
so such that
these uh normalization is similar to the
initialization method that people
typically used
yeah
so that yeah the
scale of the predicted weights like the
range of values is approximately yeah
the same as uh in the randomly
initialized networks so there's like
yeah i mean this yeah yeah this this
here this this looks a lot like sort of
the
the formulas for
take incoming and outgoing number of of
of unit of units and normalized by that
you even use here the fan in and fan
outs and i think these are these are
terms people recognize from
initializations
which i guess yeah this it makes it
makes sense at least as sort of
intuitively and then this is what i this
is here what i found um
one of the interesting parts is these
virtual edges that you introduce so we
said that these um
arc these graphs that you build they
mirror the
the neural networks essentially they
represent the architectures of the
neural networks specifically the
computation graphs and you have some
examples right here now they're a bit
small but this could be this is i guess
something like a convolutional neural
network with a residual connection is
the the left one right because
essentially the the blue here are conf
modules and you can see these conv
modules like here is one here is one and
then you can also see there's kind of
different paths
and then there's always normalizations
and so on so these are convents with
residual connections yeah as a
computational as a computational graph
right here right right yes something
like that and
so that you
you've somehow found that that is it's
not enough to build the graph like this
you can you can do better by introducing
more connections between things how did
you
get about this right so the problem is
that uh
the the node propagation uh step that we
talked about like
just uh before
uh
has the problem of uh propagating
through the long a sequence of nodes
yeah so the final node
which will be usually a classification
layer
will have little information about uh
features in the first
uh in yeah like in the first layers
and that's a problem yeah because uh
essentially
uh graph hyper network doesn't know much
about the overall global graph structure
when making predictions so this virtual
uh connections uh improve like global
context and how do you decide so you
this it looks something here is a uh an
example you give from a of kind of a
like an illustration illustratory graph
that the computational graph in in dark
and the virtual edges in green how do
you decide which things to connect
so we use the shortest path distance
between nodes
and we scale the edge this vertical edge
weight according to the inverse of this
shortest path this distance so is at the
end is everything connected to
everything uh we have some like cut off
that we don't don't connect too far
nodes okay yeah but so that you're
saying the parameters of the virtual
edges here they're
shared with the parameters of or do they
have their own parameters on parameters
uh so there is a in equation four uh you
know there is a mlp sp yeah so that's uh
like a separate network so to avoid the
confusion between real edges and uh uh
virtual okay yeah
i mean i guess the the edges they don't
have weights themselves but you do you
do make when you propagate through the
graph neural network through these
functions you do make it a difference
between the real edges and the in edges
you introduced right so in a virtual
case uh instead of just averaging
features of neighbors it's a weighted
weighted average where the weight is
okay yeah coming from the shortest path
distance cool and i guess i i think i
find it a bit funny right that you you
are
in in the hyper network essentially you
again run into the problem well what if
our network is too deep which is
essentially the same problem that
resnets had yeah before res and then
your your solution is also hey let's
introduce like residual connections
between things so that information can
flow
further it's it's kind of funny to see
that sort of the
the yeah the problems repeat one level
up and then of course the it's a it's a
different thing than a residual edge in
a in a network because this isn't the
network this is the input to the network
but it's uh
it's kind of analogous right to a
residual connection yeah yeah that's
true and that's uh that was our
motivation basically yeah and then the
last thing is this meta batching um
which
do you want to maybe talk about this a
little i understood this as
you essentially
what what's the difference between this
and and um mini batching uh so mini
batching uh
well uh usually we refer to
a batch of images right so we
for each training iteration we sample a
mini batch say of 64 images
but uh
in the baseline ghm they sample a single
architecture
for each training iteration so it's a
single architecture and 64 images
uh now the gradient becomes very noisy
because for each architecture
the
the gradients are quite different
yes and to improve that uh like
stability of convergence uh we sample a
batch of
uh architectures of architectures and a
batch of images yeah yeah or
okay so and then do you do is it
do you do x1 architecture one x2
architecture two or do you sort of build
x1 actually build up a matrix and then
pass each image through each of the
architectures in in the batch uh no we
uh just do the first option the idea
so you just sample a bunch of i guess
the analogous would be if i train a
regular neural network the analogy would
be i you know if i just always sample
from one class
because for example in imagenet the data
set is structured into these folders
right and every folder has one class
yeah if i want to make my life easy i
just go you know i do ls
of the data set and then i just go
through it and then i always sample from
one class that would give me a very bad
gradient because in the same batch i
always have examples from the from the
same class and here you're saying the
problem was that people in the same
batch they always had the exact same
architecture yeah and you get a much
much better
um estimate i guess of the gradient if
these are sampled at random it makes
makes a lot of sense cool and yeah so
that's that's where we get to the to the
experiment i think the the
um
experiments
the the main things we've already sort
of taken away in that this is on um on
c410 right here uh you have the test set
um
sort of you always split into average
and and max
uh
which is
sort of
performance
is that that's test set performance
right it's a test images and test
architectures and the most images and
test architectures from and the max is
the maxis over what exactly over
architecture so it's like the best
what what what's the performance of the
best architecture that yeah okay i i
guess that's a fair a fair metric to
look at because
you know each architecture if you were
to train it doesn't have the same
performance at the end right so with
with the max you can expect that
um the max
uh would be an architecture that if you
trained it had sort of the
state-of-the-art performance of
at least the networks you consider the
architectures you consider so maybe for
c410 that might be
96-ish
percent 97
yeah and
yeah so you get some yeah sorry yeah we
compared to sgd uh below right uh yeah
and you have a similar sort of phenomena
yeah that you have average performance
and you have like the best performance
that is a bit higher
okay so that's yeah 90 i see that 90 93
for 50 epochs i guess the
state-of-the-art things they are reached
with a bunch more tricks like uh yeah
like augmentation more implementation
yeah yeah i see yeah okay but i mean
there is a considerable gap but it's
it's still pretty cool to see right that
you get especially um also the
improvements that you make in within
this parameter prediction regime uh with
these new models or quite considerable
and so if i consider for example from
this
or this which are 60 to 77 which is
sort of like
80 and then that's like almost half of
the way of the error right that you make
compared to state of the art that's
pretty really good and even on the out
of distribution it seems the effect is
even more
um drastic right so do you do you have
any idea in
to why
why on a on the out of distribution set
your performance
it drops but it doesn't drop too much
whereas these other methods performances
they drop much more right so i think uh
like those three tricks uh play a
different role in each uh out of
distribution split
for example in the wide case i think
what helps and we have those ablations
in the appendix
what helps is parameter normalization
because when you have like a lot of uh
weights then it's important like that
they are appropriate scale
and in case of for deeper
architectures i guess what's important
is to capture this global context
because yeah the network is
yeah has a lot of nodes yes
and similar like for other
uh
splits
yeah so i well for for others please
maybe it's less intuitive what exactly
uh like
what single component makes it work but
i guess some interplay between like
those three tricks
help nice yeah and so and then at the
end you say
um so you have a you have a lot of
ablations which is really cool to to see
and open source code and and everything
uh that that is i think a lot very
appreciated especially on a more exotic
task like this one
you also are able to predict some
properties like you know what's the
accuracy of the network and so on where
you make sure that your network really
learns some kind of intrinsic properties
right of the of the networks you're
predicting so the network's not only
able to predict the weights but it's
also able to say you know what's the
what's going to be the inference speed
of the network what's going to be the
approximate accuracy on that it's going
to have and so on which really makes
sure
or it's at least a bit of a
a bit of of a confirmation that you're
doing something
um
meaningful instead of just copying over
weights so this would be to counter
anyone that says well you're just kind
of copying over
from the training set
and then the last thing is you then also
experiment fine
tuning
um
fine-tuning the predicted parameters now
obviously in in this regime we're kind
of like meta learning right we are
learning a good initialization and from
that initialization i can then fine-tune
uh but then so my question is how much
time does that save me if i use your
network to predict the initial
parameters of a resnet 50 how much less
time do i have to invest into
fine-tuning it
if as compared to compared to training
it from the beginning so we actually
provide
speeds in the table and you can see the
difference of
time
you you need so it's not as much as you
want maybe
so
as you see we
like uh predict parameters is like in
less than a second but you can achieve
the same result by
pre-training on imagenet
for
like half an hour or one hour yeah
um
sometimes more like on transformers
it takes more time
to achieve the same performance so yeah
would you say it's it's uh it's kind of
would you say your work is
maybe shows that something like this can
be done or do you do you think we'll get
to a place where
we can make so much
savings
because we only have to fine-tune for
like a tiny bit
that people say yes i'm really going to
use this instead of training from the
beginning or do you think
it might be mostly an academic exercise
no i think we can arrive at that uh
if you can see if we train for just five
epochs
uh yeah on imagenet then we all almost
get the same performance as we train for
100 epochs or like 200 epochs
uh yeah like slightly worse uh
and uh my hope is that if we are able to
predict parameters that are similar to
five epochs then we are done uh with
we don't need to predict the performance
of a 100 e-book network yeah
yeah i see yeah i mean it makes it makes
sense it it would save like it saves
like a bunch of time
and and resources and everything and
potentially allows us to investigate new
and better architectures much faster
rather than and especially if we scale
to larger models like if this holds also
for gpt style models especially if it
generalizes to way larger
architectures right it might even be
that we're at a point where
we we get such a large model that
it's prohibitive to train it from the
beginning
but we might be able to predict and then
tune
so so technically like implementation
wise
our yes in our model we can't predict
the model
we can't protect parameters we sorry we
can't predict
parameters for a network with trillion
parameters yeah sure because yeah
because we use this styling right so we
can predict exactly
but of course it will be very
bad
it may be difficult to fine-tune as well
and so the last thing i want to get into
is sort of the reception now you have
said previously to me that it has been
kind of maybe received a bit
um out of context or you know a bit
oversold what do you what do you mean by
this i think uh maybe people got an
impression that we can predict uh
parameters for
a new task
like for unseen tasks which is not true
yeah and
even though i mentioned that we only
make a single like a small step towards
replacing sgd i think people misread it
and
and understood it's like oh we replay we
are ready to replace no we are not there
yet
it's far
far away from that yeah the thumb you
can see the video thumbnail going
something like um
sgd
not needed anymore predict parameters
for any neural network
we are done
that that's the title i was trying to uh
convince my coasters
i mean it's a good vision it's a good
it's a nice vision to have right um but
yeah it's important to point out you do
generalize very well to unseen
architectures but it's always within the
same task now i guess the hope for the
future maybe you're already working on
this or or not
would also be to investigate
generalization across data sets maybe
you can imagine a situation where you
have your system on imagenet but then
you
um so you've trained it for imagenet and
then you maybe give it a little bit of
the data set of a new task and it's it's
able to adapt really quickly to that or
something like this right so it would
already be
quite useful i think
right and there are already works that
actually do that like in the meta
learning sense but
yeah normally they don't generalize well
across architectures so they generalize
well across tasks that's their focus yes
but not across architecture so there
should be a way to combine
those two
yeah sounds exciting all right i think
um this is a it's a really neat overview
over the paper um
we'll end it here boris thank you so
much for for coming here
and
yeah good good luck on your future
research yeah thank you for inviting me
and it was very fun to go through the
paper
so yeah i'm very
happy thanks a lot